cd diane travaillent ensemble depuis
presque dix ans elle partage un
dévouement commun pour les démunis et
les chiens abandonnés afin de préserver
leur amitié
elle ne parle jamais de politique
ensemble ils ont fait une exception pour
nous afin qu'ils puissent républicaine
depuis toujours
cindy a tout de même des réserves à
l'égard du président ouais comme celle
de cette entrevue
la démocrate devait la faire avec son
mari républicaine qui a refusé parce
qu'il considère le canada et les médias
comme des ennemis et aux brimades sa
note bernard bigras
ping entre temps
[Musique]
pour souvent entendus à washington une
jolie petite ville dans le sud ouest de
la pennsylvanie
la région qui a longtemps été un
château-fort démocrate a viré au rouge
en 2016
beaucoup de républicains ont refusé de
nous parler certains ont dit avoir peur
de voir leurs voitures vandalisées ou
leur commerce et 110
dylan pensent que les déclarations
incendiaires du président aiguise les
divisions jusque dans son couple
s'installe en pointe noire et gay men
women bac
[Musique]
les deux familles dénoncent est
partisanerie agressive qui divise la
population
les deux crèmes les violences où l'on
ait des élections
[Musique]
les deux lits soit racler débat
politique redevienne plus heureux en
attendant elle jure que la politique
n'aura pas raison de leur amitié
non